this video is sponsored by - Lee climate
change is scary it's possibly the
biggest threat civilization has ever
faced
- very briefly summarize human activity
has increased carbon dioxide
concentrations in the atmosphere
increases in co2 must have a warming
effect on the surface because physics
the earth is warmed by approximately one
degree on average since the eighteenth
century and our best models of the
Earth's system can really reproduce this
warming if human influence on the
climate is included so humans have
definitely changed the global climate
for the warmer by emitting co2 and other
gases like methane and we're continuing
to emit those gases every year the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change warns that if we don't limit
further emissions then we will see
further warming but also rising sea
levels more extreme hot weather events
and increases in the frequency of both
droughts and heavy precipitation this
will result in society-wide changes and
most probably extensive conflict over
migration and resources if you're
anything like me you're used to hearing
about climate change in this tone
described in much the same way as winter
in Game of Thrones winter is coming it's
coming there's nothing we can do to stop
it it's definitely coming and when it
gets here it's going to be really put up
nevermind too late Solutions to climate
change are rarely discussed because well
it's a very complex problem everyone on
earth contributes to the greenhouse gas
emissions which fuel climate change dope
not equally these contributions take
place on an individual level through our
daily activities but take place through
networks of actors the companies we
choose to do business with the banks we
trust with our money the governments
that we choose to elect our choices in
this regard in the larger scale of the
economy and political landscape have
truly enormous repercussions when people
write articles on what we can do to
mitigate climate change they very much
focus on the individual actions we take
for example not eating meat or using
public transport and these are things we
should be doing I'm not arguing against
individual action to combat climate
change but consider that we are endpoint
users in a vast network which we have
ultimate collective control over and a
far more effective way of reducing our
greenhouse gas emissions and preventing
climate catastrophe is to change the
workings of that network from the
top-down over the course of this video
I'm going to make three recommendations
of what we as voters and activists can
do to accomplish just that to begin with
consider a breakdown of where
greenhouse gas emissions come from by
sector while agriculture industry and
forestry all make modest contributions
the overwhelming majority humanity's
greenhouse gas emissions come from
energy use note that that's different
from electricity generation energy use
encompasses lots of things including
electricity generation but also heating
cooling and cooking transportation
manufacturing and other miscellaneous
uses of energy if we're to beat climate
change then we need to revolutionize how
we use energy in a general sense
transitioning away from fossil fuels
like coal and gas to renewable sources
such as wind solar geothermal and
hydropower the role of nuclear power is
a topic for a future video accomplishing
a society-wide energy transformation is
a daunting task but the world's energy
experts have been thinking about this
for a long time the International
nonprofit ren21
based at the UN Environment Programme
has produced a document every year since
2005 called the global status report
the GSR is written with contributions
from energy experts politicians and
researchers from around the world
assessing where we're at with the
renewable energy transition the full
report is available for anyone to read
link in the description having read it I
want to make three arguments for what we
should be focusing on to accelerate the
energy transition bring greenhouse gas
emissions down and beat climate change
firstly targets need to be set by
politicians for renewables uptake beyond
electricity generation we're all
familiar with the drive to replace
coal-fired power stations with wind
turbines nuclear and solar power plants
of the 197 countries in the world
146 have targets for the use of
renewable technology to generate
electricity and these targets are
working in 2017 twenty six point five
percent of energy used as electricity
came from renewable sources however as
we saw earlier energy use means much
more than just electrical power in
particular it means transport and
heating and the uptake of modern
renewables in these sectors is much
lower ten point three percent for
heating and just naught point three
percent for transport the likely reason
a lack of targets only 48 countries have
renewable energy targets for heating and
cooking and only 42 for transport in
order for the energy transition to
happen across all set
governments must commit to targets for
renewable energy use in heating and in
transportation so what can you do ask
your local representative about this and
vote for a vertical part see that
pledges to implement these targets
secondly and I'm going to say this
appropriately loudly there is a common
perception that renewable energy is fine
and dandy in principle but just too
expensive to make economic sense in
reality this is completely wrong in this
terribly formatted figure from the
International Renewable Energy Agency
the cost per kilowatt hour of fossil
fuel power generation is compared to
that of various renewable power sources
in 2010 and 2017 almost all of the
technologies shown are either cost
competitive or substantially cheaper per
kilowatt hour than traditional fossil
fuels and getting cheaper people assume
that renewables are only used because of
subsidies and incentives given to
renewable power suppliers and this can
be further from the truth
fossil fuels are subsidized
significantly more than renewables in
2016
370 billion dollars were given in
subsidies for fossil fuel use and only
140 billion given to renewables if you
factor in other externalities like
health and pollution then subsidies
given to fossil fuels are an order of
magnitude greater so despite renewables
being increasingly the lowest cost
option in fact in some cases last year
it was cheaper to build new renewables
generation than to maintain old fossil
fuel capacity money is still given to
subsidize and develop fossil fuel use by
governments the g20 has committed to
phasing out inefficient fossil fuel
subsidies but hasn't defined inefficient
or done anything on the subject since
saying so in 2009 it is imperative that
our governments commits to rapidly
phasing out fossil fuel subsidies
stopping distortion of the power market
and allowing the energy transition to
take place again write to your local
representative about this and vote for a
political party that pledges to phase
out these subsidies
lastly more money needs to be invested
in renewable energy in particular in
developing countries it's estimated by
the International Energy Agency that to
keep global temperature rise below 2
degrees Celsius 12 trillion dollars must
be
vested in renewable power supplier
between now and 2014 that translates to
about five hundred billion dollars a
year or roughly twice what the world is
currently investing at the moment we're
not going to hit the targets set by the
Paris agreements we need to be more
ambitious interestingly while most
investment in renewable energy in 2017
came from developed countries the top
three being China the USA and Japan the
highest spend per capita was in
developing countries it's estimated that
90% of people currently with our
electricity access will gain this access
through renewables mostly off-grid
distributed renewables in developing
countries in this process will take
approximately 50 billion dollars a year
in private and public funds and is
essential to funds to continued
development of these countries without
committing to massive further emissions
as such projects in developing countries
using renewable energy generation
must be prioritized by Development
Bank's and by foreign aid and absolutely
prioritized over projects using fossil
fuels further investment in developed
countries which fell more than 18% in
2017 must continue in particular in the
flexibility of energy infrastructure man
I really hope there's at least one
Energy Minister then stop watching this
otherwise that line was pointless so if
you live in a developing country vote
for a political party which prioritizes
investment in economically viable
renewable energy over fossil fuels well
if you're lucky enough to have a say in
where charity or development money goes
prioritize investment in renewable
energy access in the developing world
there are myriad aspects to the energy
transition I didn't even touch on the
issue of cooking or biofuels or carbon
taxes for example this video could never
hold all the answers to our climate
problems hell if it did I will be
holding a Nobel Peace Prize in my hands
right now what I hope it's demonstrated
is that there are specific meaningful
actions you can take beyond the
individual level to combat climate
change make your voice heard with your
vote write to your local representative
about these issues share this video so
others can learn from it too and spread
the word about these three points which
we should all be demanding from our
governments anthropogenic climate change
is an issue that has taken a world to
create and we'll take a world to unmake
we've already damaged the planet in
that will take thousands of years to
repair but through collective action we
can turn the tide limit our greenhouse
gas emissions and limit the further
damage we do to the world of our
children the best time for action was 20
years ago the second best time is now to
do a smooth segue from such a serious
topic into this video sponsor would be
inappropriate so I'm just gonna say it
as it is this video was sponsored by -
Lane - Lane is a tool which generates
securely stores and automatically fills
out online forms with strong passwords
if you're anything like me you probably
use a small number of relatively weak
passwords across a lot of websites and
have to reset them all the time because
you keep forgetting which one you used
where - Ling gets around this by
creating strong passwords and
remembering them for you and not only
other perspective than they are in your
brain they're safer than they are in
your brain
everything gets encrypted by - Ling's
patented security architecture so only
you can access what your passwords are
it syncs your passwords and online
logins across multiple devices works on
Mac Windows iOS and Android and is
trusted by more than 10 million users
worldwide I switched over to - Lane and
I doubt I'll ever switch back to
remembering all my passwords manually it
just makes the internet safer quicker
and easier you can try a 30-day free
trial on one device go to - Tang comm /a
Simon Clark and if you'd like to upgrade
to premium than the first 200 people to
use the promo code Simon Clarke will get
10% off thank you for watching this
video it's been a very important one to
me so I've taken my time to get this one
right please do share it widely as this
message is the most important message we
could be spreading right now please see
the description for links and references
and footnotes and thank you again for
watching I'll see you in the next one